occasionally you hear or read something
and think
that can't be right i mean surely i must
have read or heard that wrong and that
was precisely my reaction when i read
san francisco and new york were going to
pay people not to shoot one another or
otherwise commit
violent crimes
paying someone not to shoot us is sort
of what we have to do in carjackings and
bank robberies and armed robberies we
pay money to stay alive it's a version
of blood money or extortion
and sometimes money is paid to keep
someone else alive like in kidnapping
cases and that's called a ransom so yes
sometimes criminals are paid not to kill
and sometimes in the heat of the moment
when forced to choose between money and
our lives we will pick our lives
i just never thought government or any
other non-criminal enterprise would
actually encourage this kind of
shakedown or extortion
i mean think about where we are as a
country right now some progressives are
advocating for cutting funding to cops
but paying criminals so they will stop
at least until the check clears being
criminals
i want you to let that sink in for a
second really
think about that
some progressives want to stop paying
cops
but start paying
criminals
and these are the same folks who tell us
we need more social workers and more
psychologists because
we all know how great social workers are
at processing crime scenes and
collecting dna samples
and now we need more cash cards and gift
certificates so those who do not value
life
can at least learn to value the dollar
money has become the new morality
what about not shooting people because
it's wrong i mean that used to be what
we talk
you don't commit crimes because to do so
is to break the social contract
is it still okay to teach people killing
and robbing and assaulting people is
wrong or do we have to pay protection
money
what a mess this culture is in may
taxpayers in this country
already spend a lot of money to prevent
crime the number one crime prevention
strategy we have
is called school
it's called an education
you want to reduce crime
make kids get an education
you want to live in a safer community
make sure your children your
grandchildren your nieces and your
nephews graduate high school at a
minimum
we spend
so much money on education so we can
offer some hope offer a better way of
life offer a glimmer of opportunity we
spend money on after-school programs
we spend money on a social safety net so
those down on their luck go won't go
without housing or food or health care
we spend money on public transportation
this country already provides a ladder
for those who want to ascend
and a safety net to catch those who fall
but apparently that isn't enough now we
must also pay you not to kill
us what about the kids who would never
think about hurting someone else
what about the children in san francisco
and new york or any other large american
city who do not need to be bribed to
follow the law they do not need to be
paid a ransom to value human life
what about just a shared sense of
humanity
what about the accountability that we
should
all feel toward one another just by
virtue of being fellow citizens fellow
human beings
what about the kids in these cities
working two jobs
one to help support a family and one to
save for the dream of going to college
if you have so much money you can afford
to pay people not to kill us
do you also have enough money to pay
people who want to go to college to
become a nurse or a firefighter or a
teacher or heaven forbid a police
officer are we just going to pay those
who are thinking about taking a life
or can we at least also consider paying
those who are thinking about
saving lives
since when did we start paying the
troublemakers but ignoring the kids
who are doing the right thing and since
when did the path to prosperity get
paved without any convictions
if your state or city is so flush with
cash that you just cannot find new and
innovative ways to waste it
why not pay the kids who actually
deserve it
why not reward the behavior we want to
incent rather than pay ransom money to
keep people from hurting us
defund the cops
but pay career criminals not to commit
more crimes
and we wonder why so many people think
this country
is on the wrong track